that guy walling camp or whatever was
all teo'd huh
molly is it mulling camp mullins hans
mullen camp
now i've worked with the feller have you
i worked with a fellow for
and now is he a decent man or what kind
of man is he yeah he's a decent is he
tall or what kind of man is he he's
about six he's about six two probably
240
250. okay so he's uh that's heavyweight
huh is that light heavyweight that's
heavy
that's heavyweight that's why dom wanted
to do a
charity match with him oh it'd be a
great fight
i don't think so you don't no
don don would absolutely beat the [ __ ]
out of him and is the man a registered
uh
he's a black belt oh he's a black belt
he's been in the word he's a black belt
under your boy
who's that uh dustin no no no no no no
uh your boy
[ __ ] the guy in san diego black belt
under who uh
you know who i'm talking about no no no
no no the special forces now hold on
are you talking about um
a black belt under who
uh jock you're talking about jacob he's
a black belt jocko
and uh realistic yeah which is pretty
legit
oh i'm not i'm not saying it's not legit
dude i'm a white fellow yeah i know i'm
saying he'll roll you the [ __ ] up is
what i'm trying to do so
watch your p's and q's my walling count
yep
he's a thick boy again if i was paying
100
if i gained 100 i i'm not saying i could
take him but i'm saying i would
you would entertain a celebrity fight
dude i'll beat that what did you say
monster easy on the celebrity heavy on
the fight what
he sells monster yeah he slanks a
monster that poison juice
dude i'll drink half a [ __ ] can of
bang and beat that dude oh
bang it up doug dude i'll do two lines
of [ __ ] johnson and johnson baby
powder and [ __ ] wrap that
wrap that bad boy up now you're gonna
have to deal with big gene in nashville
first i feel like she's been whipping
that ass since day one
yeah i was i'd like to see her and hans
go at it
again i've never had any issues with
dude he was always cool to me
but i would like to see him and dom go
at it obviously you don't though
like you don't well i mean if you want
to see a straight up beat down
you i mean if you don't like the guy you
want to see that do you think dominic
would beat him
beat the [ __ ] breaks off of him i
look i like dominic man because he
always
he always he just brings an edge to
stuff he's exciting
you know say what you people say this
and that and he can't beat this guy
and they stop that fight early and this
and that but
the guy uh i'd love to see he's exciting
yeah he's older you know he's older you
look good though good win
yeah let the guy fight let him fight who
cares uh who knows if monster energy is
even really a helpful tool for fighters
put it to the [ __ ] test have they got
have them each drink two cans of monster
that's fair have them [ __ ] put some
ivs injected straight to the dome dog
dude that's what i'm saying get a can of
[ __ ] there he is right there
that's why dom's like dude what the [ __ ]
he's like what are you gonna do for my
money's like get on the front of this
bike dog
look like my [ __ ] yeah i want you to
look like e.t for me on this [ __ ]
bike
no that's a bit much dude and he made
him wear the
would you do it for 5k huh would you do
that for 5k
ride that little bike yeah you'll be on
the front though no if i was on the back
yeah i was going to say i'd give you 5k
right in the front like that with me
if i could ride on his back while he
drove it ooh that'd be fun
that looks like you and me almost yeah
it does just being down with a cruise in
2014.
wow what were you guys talking about
what do you have a suit on and why are
you dressed like you're about to
suck blood later that evening oh my god
you look like an extra [ __ ] true
blood what's going on there why is he
obviously
you're obviously wasting and he's
obviously asking you to not talk with
what the him else you want man yeah dude
why are you [ __ ]
dressed why are you grilling me about
monster energy drinks
yeah why are you dressed like [ __ ]
somebody who like a
[ __ ] vampire dog
dominic cruz man you know i like
dominick cruz man
i think dominic cruz should come he's so
you never know what he's gonna do he's
like kind of angry and he's [ __ ]
but he's not afraid to confront people
on air no dude i think he should come
out with dominic cruz lines you know
and it's like a ship you get on it you
don't really know where it's gonna go
dude
it might hit other ships it's constantly
like shaking and going like all these
different ways it'll go on land
you're like oh my god this boat like a
rubber boat
yeah damn this might be an ohio you
might end up in florida you might end up
in the [ __ ] you know
yeah you might end up with that strap
dude yeah i love it i love it man so
business tag team match here's what i'm
saying tag me match
you me and cruz finally i'm trying to
get the look
it's so hard to obviously get brendan to
do anything so i'm trying to get you to
do something
so what i'm saying is me and chris
you're the biggest celebrity me and cruz
okay be in the rock versus you and
holland camp no
not big enough hmm not big enough
look man i'm gonna i'm gonna say it to
you again i don't think you heard me i
think you're hearing other stuff and
then i heard you
i think you're hearing like spelling
lessons i heard you
okay me now you're not now you're not
watching a pay-per-view you're not
trying to get on the broadcaster
okay wow you throw me under the [ __ ]
pay-per-view boss just because they
won't put your tweets through dude i
don't tweet during the fight yes you do
i'm watching
the fights unless it's extreme like
controversy i don't tweet during the
fights man
i watch the fights here's what i'm
offering you brendan i'm offering you a
business thing
okay but you you gotta you gotta come
with a little more let me talk to tiger
put tiger on the phone
okay boston might do it
open boston is the ring card girl okay
facts bro here's what i'm saying me
and john uh jollin camp
versus you and cruz and cruise yeah
no no [ __ ] i [ __ ] it up me and cruz
versus you and john camp
that happened half a mil for half a m
and we all
so we got so that's 250 yeah but another
250 if you guys win
we have to split it up in the ring they
dump the money in the room that'd be
cool
you guys have to divide it right there
that'll be dope here you go man
dude how long is ufc away from putting
that winning cash just in the ring and
having them pick it up like a scrooge
mcduck vibe no like strippers bro they
treat these guys like strangers
me dominic cruz
and pat milotic verse
so it's a three-way yeah versus john
mullen camp
you okay laura sanko oh
oh one cutie and now he's here
so the problem is uh donnie mullen camp
isn't [ __ ] handsome enough